pour la première fois manuela qu'est
clarmont désirent se présente devant les
électeurs de sa commune en dix ans la
candidate aux élections municipales de
saint joseph a gravi les échelons de la
politique
conseillère régionale adjointe au maire
et depuis un an députés ce mandat obtenu
après que bruno nestor azérot ait
préféré reprendre les rênes de sainte
marie l'a propulsé au coeur du pouvoir
législatif et elle compte bien s'en
servir pour aider sa commune un ville de
vevey il nous manque dans l'organigramme
une cellule ingénierie financière et
portage de dos il est avec sa fille
nous allons chasser les financements
nous allons chercher et d'associer dans
les visions abitbol itv je peux vous
dire des dispositifs parmi ses thèmes de
campagne
la redynamisation du centre bourg avec
par exemple la création d'un marché et
la sécurisation de la commune
ce n'est pas seulement poser les caméras
mais un vrai une vraie une vraie
politique d'accompagnement des jeunes
d'insertion de formation avec les
acteurs que ce soient institutionnels
que ce soit des taxes ce soir les
acteurs économiques des propositions
d'ordre économique urbanistique est
aussi culturel pour mieux servir la
politique municipale est pour cela que
je vous propose que nous créions
l'office de la culture pas un office
municipal mais nous fit l'accueil aura
un statut associatif et qui pourra
justement soulevé des subventions en
étant en ayant un statut à se gaver avec
sa liste lieu en âge pour saint jo
avancé manuel ac et clermont désir devra
convaincre face à 80 candidatures dont
celle de yan monplaisir est simon morin
le premier adjoint du maire
un maire qui ne se représente pas et qui
ouvre donc le champ des possibles à
saint joseph
[Applaudissements]